-Let's talk about "The Voice,"
my friend.
Season 20 premiered earlier
tonight.
It's also the 10th anniversary
of the show.
What can we expect this season?
-It's my 5th season,
and I'm having a blast.
I love it.
Nick Jonas is back.
Our, uh...
-Yeah, we love him.
-Our youngest coach.
He just hosted SNL
and performed so beautifully.
And he's back as a coach
and we're having a lot of fun
this season.
-And I know Brandy is the mentor
this season for Team Legend.
Have you -- I can't remember.
Have you worked with Brandy
before?
-I worked with her once.
We had a song together called
"Quickly."
It was on my 3rd album, Evolver,
and it was actually written by
Frank Ocean, so that's
a pretty cool combination.
Me, Brandy singing together,
a song written by Frank Ocean.
But we hadn't worked together
since then,
and I love Brandy.
I love her as a vocalist.
I've looked up to her for such
a long time.
And so many of my singers on my
team just are super Brandy fans,
and I told her that she isn't
just a great singer,
she's a singer's singer.
That so many artists, so many
singers look up to her
as an example of just a great,
great vocalist.
And every time my artists walked
in and discovered Brandy was
their mentor, they just all were
in shock and so thrilled.
And we were so lucky to have
Brandy.
-Well, you know what it's like
to be on a show like
"The Voice,"
because as a kid, I heard that
you wanted to be on
one of the original singing
competition shows,
"Star Search," which I'm not
sure...
-I wanted to be on "Star Search"
so badly.
You know, I used to grow up
watching Ed McMahon --
-Ed McMahon!
-And...
-Three and three quarter stars!
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
And so many great artists
actually came through
"Star Search," and I would watch
the show
and I was like,
"I want to be on there.
I deserve to be on there."
And then my local mall --
it was called
the Fairfield Commons Mall,
outside of Dayton, Ohio.
They had a local "Star Search"
competition
and if you won the local
competition,
they would send your tape to
national "Star Search."
So I won the local "Star Search"
competition
at the mall of Fairfield Commons
outside of Dayton.
They sent my videotape to the
national "Star Search,"
and I never got a call back,
so that was that.
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, my God.
-But I did -- I did get a $500
shopping spree
at the new mall,
and...
-That's a lot.
-I bought a lot of clothes.
So, I was happy.
-I want to show a clip --
here's a look at tomorrow
night's episode of "The Voice."
Check it out.
-It's an amazing feeling to feel
the joy
that you have when you perform.
It's very infectious.
Not only can you sing, but
you're a real musician
and you come with artistry.
I would love to work with an
artist like you.
-And he's not a liar.
-Wait. Wait a minute.
-Blake is going to lie some
more, so.
[ Laughter ]
-I am the only coach who doesn't
live in Hollywood.
I don't ever want to lose sight
of my roots.
-Wait, what?!
-All three of you have gone
Hollywood.
-You came to Hollywood
and started dating Gwen Stefani.
[ Laughter ]
The ultimate...
-The Queen of Orange County.
-The manifestation of
California girl.
-You see how ugly it gets here?
-I see, I see it.
-John Legend.
Tune in tomorrow night at 9 PM
on NBC for more of "The Voice"
blind auditions.